good morning millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy Monday I know it's
Dreadful but there's so much that needs
to be discussed like don't even worry
about it okay it takes the dread out of
Monday because I just there's so much to
say so much has been unfolding over the
weekend aside from all the drama the
vampire rules drama like show me so much
content this weekend like I feel like
I'm all caught up on pop culture which
is not a feeling I feel very often these
days so it's got a lot to say yeah
there's so much to discuss of course
pump rules major bombshell on a Friday
afternoon and you know like the way you
know this is a big deal because it was a
Friday afternoon like people don't care
about stuff if you're looking to bury a
piece of news you release it on a Friday
afternoon the way it has carried through
it is everywhere Twitter like people who
don't know it's kind of like remember
when like two months ago the try guys
had like big drama and everyone was
talking about it we're like what the
[__] is the try guys that's happening
for people who don't know about
Vanderpump Rules yeah because this is
one of the craziest things that could
have happened in the Vanderpump Rules
Universe in reality TV period honestly
yeah and things keep coming out so like
even this morning there's like new news
and there's just so many layers to this
and everybody has an opinion there's so
many cast members it's just you could go
on and on and on and everyone's getting
involved nobody's staying silent except
for Raquel
yeah we'll talk about everyone's getting
involved nobody's staying silent sure
um I'm also all just caught up on
Vanderpump Rules I figured you know I
need to get back on track because shit's
about to pop off apparently they were
filming yeah so Zach and I watch
Vanderpump Rules Friday night after the
news dropped and we've been keeping up
and I should have watched that episode
last week but I didn't and the way I
literally could not even watch the show
I was so
blinded by what had happened like
everything Raquel did I was like how
dare she like literally it was so crazy
to watch it knowing what we know
it's almost frustrating because
everything we're seeing yeah it's like
cool to like look for now that we know
look for Clues but it's annoying like
what's going on no wait I need a live
stream right now what's so crazy is I
was looking at the dates so they said
they've been having an affair for seven
months which would mean it started in
July
2022. the Schwartz and Sandy's Daily
Mail party was in July of 2020. so like
the affair is starting to happen and
it's it's crazy to watch
people lying this whole like Schwartz
kissing thing is completely decoy yeah
and you're just like watching everyone
lie
um and so I if it was completely
irrelevant and they didn't even have it
started anything like I would say yeah
like let's catch up but I find this
fascinating I thought we were like a few
months out honestly so that's super
interesting thank you for sharing Jackie
and I are going to be breaking down the
entire Saga um as one of the stories
we're also going to be talking about
Chris Rock's new special which live
streamed on Netflix which was pretty
cool I watched it not live
um I watched it live I was a part of
something no that's exciting I was a
part of something we waited we turned on
early Leslie Jones was doing standing
and then we watched live and it was
there was so much to discuss it's a
story we're going to talk about the
biggest Bombshells and our overall
thoughts great um SNL was also on it was
a big weekend for the Kelsey's Travis
Jason and Kelsey
um I have to say it was a really really
like atrocious episode like maybe one of
the worst in terms of writing uh Travis
there was like a few funny moments like
Travis um as an American Girl doll like
single doll dad like that was funny and
cute and he had some good lines I
thought Heidi Gardner did a really
actually hysterical job in the sketch
where she runs into her boyfriend in the
bar and then Jason Kelsey Jason Kelsey
save that sketch the show was positively
Dreadful and I only watch SNL when
there's someone that I want to see and
every single time I Come Away with the
same thought like this is the greatest
comedic Minds in America like aren't we
embarrassed like yeah I found that to be
embarrassing that that's what passes for
comedy yeah there were a few sketches
that like didn't make me clench my butt
cheeks and cringe straight male friend
hilarious
I don't know about hilarious concept it
was executed well and I have to say
Travis Kelsey did a really good job of
being like an actor in the lines and and
the delivery and and not losing focus
like I was very impressed by him as a
host I thought he did a really good job
in the sketches that were terrible and
in his opening monologue he did say this
wasn't his first time hosting a show I
love that he referenced catching Kelsey
and they like showed us I can't believe
they showed us a clip I don't know and
it makes sense because NBC is peacock
whatever
um obsessed like obsessed beyond belief
we're all thinking it and now he finally
said it and it's just it's a joy to to
be to be seen like that no I I just
can't believe that like catching Kelsey
was referenced on SNL because it's such
even when he said like it's owned by NBC
Universal so it should be on peacock but
they said that they said nah
um I wish they're missing out they're
missing out I wish they did a little bit
more with his family like Jason and his
mom were in the opening monologue and
then Jason had a one second thing in the
in the sketch I wish they kind of leaned
on them more
um I don't know if whose choice that was
but uh okay like give us more I feel
like maybe it was because Jason like
couldn't get up to New York until maybe
the last minute so they weren't gonna
like give him lines and stuff and he was
a pro honestly when he went in that
sketch I was like he's a good actor like
I felt
I felt like I was watching you know a
sketch it was a real sketch yeah it was
so good when that moment happened the
rest was so terrible yeah I can't like
it was really horrible television yeah I
was in shock yeah me and Ben were like
shocked and I was so ready like I have a
low bar if I'm excited I was so excited
about Kelsey ballerini I was so excited
about Travis Kelsey like my bar was low
for me to like it and so for me to me
and Ben both walk away be like wow that
was really not funny it was it must have
been really bad no it was painful and
embarrassing and we got so much behind
the scenes content of Chase and Kelsey
like Chase was there the whole time and
they were hanging out with Travis and it
was Stokes oh I didn't see anything oh
he was posting like a ton of photos
where on his Instagram yeah like so
proud of you my love other stories yes
damn I don't follow him and I actually
just was on his Instagram in the feed
checking stuff out and it probably was
in the stories and I missed it stories
and Kelsey posted some pics of them and
she made some tick tocks because he was
like there the whole weekend like for
rehearsals and stuff it was really cute
that's insane that they're so
serious and public no it's crazy also
um we were wrong she performed two songs
from Rolling up the welcome mat she did
blindsided and Penthouse she sounded
really good vocally on Penthouse like
she because she has been playing that
song a lot that's not the first time
she's played it live on her tour in the
UK this last week she played it at every
single show so she's had like good
practice and she's worked on like some
new some new runs and some new riffs and
it sounded really good and then
blindsided was the first time she had
ever played it she added that new verse
at the end uh which was clearly like
Direct
you said you would have searched the
whole world over yeah right okay and
that's what's so funny is when we talked
about his song on the show like two
weeks ago I said I was saying how I
thought his song was sweet like I would
have searched the whole world over for
you would it be a shoulder for you and
you said yeah sure okay yeah like well
we just found out that you didn't no and
I just but you didn't but you did it and
that was the message from her verse and
I enjoyed that very much I do too she
sounded amazing she looked amazing I
like that she had tried to do blindsided
as like a pop moment and then have her
like serious piano ballad I stand by
those are not the songs I would have
chosen I really wish she did something
from Hart First like the world will knit
like I I get it like I get the choice
like the EP is having this moment you're
right it's like this very Grassroots
Olivia Rodrigo thing so people are
tuning in for the EP but those people
who are tuning in are just bandwagoners
those people who are tuning in for
Kelsey love Kelsey like I love Kelsey
I'll listen to to any song she performs
and I'm gonna love it but I just feel no
I disagree like all the hoopla people
who didn't know who she was like they're
here for the EP like the ep's connecting
with really they don't even know yeah
like they don't even know
the great hits prior to this has the EP
really won her that many new fans music
I think so I think so especially then
with call her daddy yeah yeah no I
understand like publicly like in the
like as a personality that with the call
her daddy and the drama and the divorce
like people now are talking more about
her but musically
I think so I really do especially like
from what I've seen on Tick Tock like
people who have never really ventured
into country and certainly people who
might not have known who she was but who
resonate with you know either divorce or
breaking up or whatever it's speaking to
a lot of people so I get the decision it
was a good strategy and I would have
been happy with two songs off of rolling
up the welcome mat that were a different
too like even well uh what's the first
one with a view mount with a view and
the last one lose me yeah no Penthouse
oh okay yeah I just like I am so I'm
still so in my subject to change era
like I feel
it's so good like it's and for people to
have really heard that like I feel like
that's so Kelsey and that's really her
her General genre this uh EP is it's not
really always what she the type of stuff
she puts out so I would have loved to
have seen like heart first little things
if you go down to something but just
like a bigger song I wanted a bigger
song yeah I agree like and a really
Kelsey song but she she sounded amazed
you could tell she was singing live like
she hit like every note she has a
beautiful voice I loved her look that's
what you get when you dive into country
like you're not gonna get some flop who
doesn't know how to sing and is gonna
like have background vocals that you
can't even hear their voice because like
they're not as good live you're never
gonna get that with country and that's
why I Stand country music like they
never they never disappoint and charity
Lou it's not surface lyrics
certainly not surface lyrics and I think
Ben would say the same I think he would
say the same I think he has said the
same
I can tell you for a fact that he has
um so it's just like a big content
weekend yeah other than that how was
your weekend on a personal social level
it was great I read a lot
I did what are you reading I finished
yesterday in just a matter of hours that
Thriller that's all over my Goodreads
the perfect marriage you've probably
seen the cover two rings and a lot of
blood excellent really I tore through it
gave it four out of five stars
kept me on the edge of my seat they did
not tell you what you wanted to know
till literally The Bitter End that's
annoying I would have given it five
stars but the ending I don't know I
wouldn't have chosen you know that
person to be the murderer you know oh
okay it felt like a little
um but it was a great book and it really
it held my attention all day I couldn't
put it down so that was great I also
read Mile High which is like a series of
books that everyone said I would really
like and I didn't really like it so I'm
not going to read the second series but
then that always happens people are like
the second is so much better so then
you're like all right then you get
sucked in but I I I read it it wasn't my
favorite and I'm moving on when is the
second so much better
that's a third question Ted 2 is a real
Contender not oh no no no but it's but
Ted 2 is just as good no not just as
good it's good it's really really really
good Ted one is masterful Masterpiece
yeah
descendants 2 is really good
I would say
hmm wait I got one
High School Musical three three one
always one and three are good except in
descendants it's one and two and three
is horrible
Twilight New Moon second is probably my
least favorite hangover one and three
are good
um it's the curse of the second film
perfect there was something recently
where like the second was kind of better
than the first that we were just talking
about I don't know if we'll be able to
grasp it
was it Pitch Perfect no I don't even
notes oh my God two was so bad they were
like at camp and like it was horrible at
Camp yeah I think they were at like
acapella Camp I just remember like Rebel
Wilson on a lake make it stop oh and
then they went to the international
three we bring it back that was three oh
okay okay because that one was excellent
with the Haley Steinfeld you were just
saying if anyone can remember a two
that was almost better than the one we
were just saying yeah
well no your theory stands correct even
with Bring It On
Bring It On sequel what was the second
one because the third one was Solange
and Hayden Panettiere which is no that
wasn't I don't think that was the third
one I think there were a lot but the
second one was with in college
it was some girl named like
Winifred it's always a win of Fred okay
so you're saying Solange is not the
second no because that one's so good but
those aren't sequels those are just like
remakes spit-offs you're right bring it
on is kind of its own caliber of films
you can't compare
all right well
I guess we'll never know My Big Fat
Greek Wedding ah
yes yes the second is actually you know
what the second is really it's not just
as good but it's excellent yeah
yeah
okay well that's also like they didn't
run into a sequel there was this like
this Grassroots organic movement begging
for 10 years give us a sequel so it
really I feel like sometimes they give a
sequel It's like well nobody really
asked
but not with Greek Wedding yeah
yeah
okay well I feel like we have so much
business to handle today that we should
really dive oh sorry I'm sorry how's
your weekend thank you turdy Lou it was
great it was low-key lots of family time
I sliced my fingers open trying to cut
up some cheese
and it was really nice other than the
slicing
um just great times with Harry Liv and
Harry Harry was like what saying what
about me like don't hold back just tell
me everything oh he was just saying like
Auntie Koya would love this auntie koi
should be here where's anti-coy and I
just kind of had to redirect him because
I didn't want to focus on what's not
here you know right he was probably like
wow I could really use a song right now
yeah
he he needed he needs a lot of songs to
get through the day and what about
pregio how you feeling I'm feeling good
thank you so much better like in this
trimester and this season like still
fatigued but way like night and day so
just trying to do everything I can in
the hours where I have energy
and um
what was my follow-up question it was
kind of a good one
oh does it also just feel so much better
like now that people know like like you
can like wear a shirt that's like
whatever you know yeah
yeah not so much for wear a shirt but um
just so that like I can just be honest
about like how I'm feeling like if I
were to say if you were saying how were
you this weekend and I was just like
good and tired it's like okay lazy [__]
anything else now it's like I'm pregnant
life I'm pretty like what are you doing
what did you do this weekend wench yeah
because I created a life creating it's a
long process yeah maybe I created a life
too bomb chicken
I would love that joint maternity leave
I didn't
um
but I did
okay let's dive in okay two the first
guy story is that you absolutely need to
know today like if you're gonna listen
to one episode actually I don't want to
say the rest of the week I don't want to
say nothing's gonna happen but this is a
big one so without further Ado hear the
faster stories that you need to know and
the past five stories that you need to
know are brought to you by ZocDoc so if
you've scoured the internet playing Dr
roulette for questionable reviews ZocDoc
you have a trusted guide to connect you
to your favorite doctor that you just
haven't met yet so when you're really
not feeling your best and just trying to
hold it together finding great care
shouldn't take up all your energy ain't
that the truth
when uh that's where ZocDoc comes in
using their free app that millions of
users rely on you can field the right
doctor that meets your needs and fits
your schedule you'll book an appointment
with a few TAPS in their app and start
feeling better faster today
so I have used ZocDoc for many of things
I feel like later in life I'm having new
problems where I need new Specialists
you know it's not the same old same old
can't keep going to my pediatrician I've
got job problems I've got back problems
I need Specialists and ZocDoc is a great
resource with whether you're looking for
new doctors or like Jackie moving to a
new town not having your OG go-to's
ZocDoc will find a doctor that fits your
needs that takes your insurance that has
a time that's right for you so you're
not wasting your time getting on the
phone which is like the most
uncomfortable thing ever and calling up
a million doctors like asking a million
questions ZocDoc takes a lot of the
awkwardness out of looking for a doctor
so with zoc talk there are no alarms and
no surprises go to zocdoc.com toast and
download the ZocDoc app for free then
find and book a top-rated doctor today
many are available with 20 within 24
hours ZocDoc is the only free app that
lets you find and book doctors who are
patient reviewed take your insurance and
are available when you need them and
they treat almost every condition Under
the Sun so that's
zocdoc.com toast
zocdoc.com toast many doctors are
available within 24 hours today's
episode is also brought to you by all
birds when it comes to Quality Mother
Nature knows best and you can take that
idea and run with the wool Runners from
all birds this year trade your synthetic
Footwear for wool Runners they're
crafted with premium Supernatural
materials that are comfy and durable so
you can run to the ends of the Earth or
just to the store yeah I'm not running
to the ends of the Earth but I do wear
sneakers quite a bit especially when I
travel and on Wednesday I'm taking like
the longest flight ever I have such a
long day I will be wearing my all birds
they're easy to slip on and off for
security
they're also just really comfortable I
feel like my feet get really hot in
sneakers especially when I'm like
walking around these big airports which
is a conversation I can't really get
into right now but I have a problem with
um all birds are a great travel shoe
they keep your feet cool they're really
comfortable if you're on your feet for
long amounts of hours I feel like I
maybe have flat feet like I get really
like bad pain in my feet enough about me
but all birds really I can stand around
got a nice Arch they do you can walk
around in them for a really long time
um and I just really like them so the
wool Runners are built using premium
Supernatural materials with a low
environmental impact so you'll get Next
Level comfort with zq certified
superfine Merino wool that's temperature
regulated moisture wicking and itch free
oh my God I'm so glad they brought that
up it's really like what is that when
you're wearing sneakers like you got to
put a ruler in your shoe just to scratch
the middle of your arch like it's really
annoying it has to do with the materials
in your shoe and all birds are making
sure that you're to get get no itches in
the middle of your flight
they're also machine washable so they
look as fresh as the day you got them
you don't have to worry about scuffing
them up or whatever running through the
rain just throw them in the wash
um this year take a big step forward
with Mother Nature with the all birds
wool Runner discover your perfect pair
at allbirds.com today that's
a-l-l-b-i-r-d-s.com
thank you Claudia you're welcome Jackie
our first story will start from the
beginning of the news Friday afternoon
TMZ reported that Tom Sandoval and
Ariana Maddox called it quits amid
allegations that he cheated with co-star
Raquel Levis
show sources told TMZ Ariana found about
found out about the alleged cheating in
the last couple of days so last week and
ended things with Tom shortly thereafter
they're told producers got word of what
went down and made the decision to fire
up the cameras with the entire cast to
document The Fallout in the coming days
and the hope is they'll be able to get
it into the season currently airing yeah
so they weren't filming anymore because
the season's airing but they got cameras
in there so I'm sure the season will end
and then it will be like four months
later everyone's doing interviews
they're filming people's conversations
what's interesting TMZ says is that
Ariana was with Thomas recently as
Wednesday to celebrate the release of
his new single and perform with his band
however sources close to Tom tell TMZ
the two of them have been on the outs
for some time now so I think there was
rockiness in their relationship but to
have a seven month affair with someone's
best friend is you know beyond rockiness
yeah
uh so the way it went down from what I
understand and like literally I feel
like because there are so many cast
members who actually know what happened
like they're just telling every yeah
anyone who will listen so after Tom's
show Wednesday night he had a tum and
then the most extra show which I have to
talk about yeah uh Raquel saw a text
papa I mean Ariana saw a text pop up
from Raquel on Tom's phone and it was a
video of Raquel very sexual in nature
and then she started scrolling through
text and saw more inappropriate things
and confronted Tom and found out they've
been having a seven month Affair
um Raquel had just done Watch What
Happens live with Sheena Sheena found
out about it and apparently slapped
Raquel in the face and is no longer
speaking with Raquel
well I have to say one of my initial
thoughts when catching up on the season
was like my god did Sheena plant her
flag in the wrong friend yeah like she's
really writing like making enemies out
of everyone just to like support Raquel
she knows horrible this season but this
episode
but this episode like that's a separate
conversation this episode is not about
China
um
but she's horrible
so I feel like for me this would have
blown up anyway but the second the TMZ
article came out James Kennedy posted a
screenshot of the article which made it
because if when I first saw this I was
like there's no way that's true like
yeah or no way no but when James posted
it it said this is true and then
everyone else started getting in so for
me like James really blew it up
um and I I felt so many emotions I mean
first like I not to make everything
about me like I felt so Vindicated
because I feel like for years like there
have been like you know a decent amount
of people who are obsessed with Tom
Sandoval and like I've just known from
like I just know like I can [__] read
people like I knew this man was [__]
horrendous and to watch his like midlife
crisis with his stupid band like sorry
you can't sing to watch this and just
watch how over the last years he has
really been horrible to Katie to Tom to
Stasi to Jax and I know like nobody
feels bad for Stacy Jacks but it's
important in the context of like the
history here
um I hate this man I know this man is
evil and I now have [__] proven
everybody sees what I've been seeing for
years I mean we've been saying this
and I think a lot of people feel
Vindicated like I know a lot of people
feel Vindicated like because they have
said like not trusted Tom over the years
you know Lala feels very Vindicated that
she never really liked Raquel
um I always thought Tom was like
extremely cringe and self-centered and
narcissistic and
like obsessed with the show and the fame
like to and to a point of delusion like
starting a band but this cheating on
your girlfriend I'm 10 years with one of
her best friends and have not just like
we got we're drunk and we hooked up a
seven month Affair is [__] diabolical
it is but when you really look into it
it's really not
Tom's Annabelle was with Kristen for
eight years and I know they claim that
everything they did was like you know
kosher but like I think we all know it
wasn't he that convince it wasn't uh I
kind of am I think like everyone is like
just kind of come to terms with it and
it was like okay whatever but they're
together and in love now and they're
like not married but they're in this
partnership they have a house like you
know what we all move on like even
Kristen yeah I don't but even if there
were some moments of like impropriety
I Kristen and Arianna were not friends
like that this is the same group there
were a couple moments of like maybe
kissing or something but not no I mean
this is next level like Ariana and
Raquel being best friends best friends
and it being a full-on affair
yeah I honestly it's so crazy but I do
think like how you get them is how you
lose them sort of thing and I'm not in
any way like blaming Ariana by any means
but I wasn't like once I sat down and
thought about it like I wasn't that
shocked honestly the real shocking part
is the Raquel of it all like Not only
would Tom choose a girl who's so close
with his
girlfriend but how Raquel could go the
last seven months like being so up
Ariana's ass going to all these things
with Tom and Ariana and we thought she
was going for Ariana but she was going
for Tom that's like a diabolical level
especially because what we've seen over
the last few years with Raquel on the
show is like she's kind of this like
spineless mute like she doesn't really
defend herself she's kind of quiet she
remember she cried last year because she
couldn't even make a toast in front of a
bunch of people like it's just she's not
the type of girl you would expect this
behavior from no I don't know who she is
like one the Raquel we're seeing this
season is different from Raquel's of the
past but we just you know uh attributed
it to her like coming out of her shell
maybe maybe some mistakes along the way
she's obviously drinking a lot so maybe
having you know a rough night here or
there but like a seven month Affair is
beyond you know getting a little too
drunk
I don't understand this person I don't
know this person how could you do
something like this to how could anyone
do something like this to a friend let
alone someone who's like brand for lack
of a better word is like being nice and
shy and sweet yeah it's um it's so crazy
all the all the cast mates have spoken
out I said this to you like two weeks
ago like Raquel is Gonna Save this show
and when I said it I didn't even know
what she was up to no she has become the
center of the show and now in a huge way
and I know that these are people's lives
but in terms of this show like this is
people said the show would never be the
same without like Jackson stassi all the
drama from season one The smacking
Kristen and Jax this is pump 2.0 like I
never expected for me the show was on
its way out like it would even though
the season is good and their stuff the
show was slowly dying this has breathed
a new life into the franchise like
everyone really should be thanking Tom
and Raquel because
so many people have started watching
Vanderpump Rules this weekend like who
have never even watched a single and
people who watched for years but took
time off know who Raquel and Tom
Campbell and Ariana are they're backing
and they're watching this season now and
the people who have been watching like
me who I I just Associated like I don't
need all the drama in order for me to
like it I just like some of the people
but now I'm like oh my God it's top of
mind so in that from an entertainment
value perspective like this is how to
save the show 100 and also like for all
the cast members who are so mad at Tom
and Raquel like they can't stop talking
about it and they're you know going on
Instagram stories and they're popping
off and everyone it's so weird how
everyone feels the need to post team
Ariana it's like there's no other team
to be on no literally and I feel like I
actually have had like a unique
relationship with Ariana in terms of my
I really have never fully like loved her
just because she's with Tom's animal
like I have a deep hatred and I don't
really understand how anyone could like
him but now that not only is she not
with him she probably [__] it and hates
him I feel like I'm about to build this
ship so big for just Ariana like I feel
I feel ready to stand like I've never
stand before I think that's how everyone
feels both in the cast and outside of
the cast and she's always in like a
really great level-headed yeah character
within the show always weird to us that
she was with Tom and could be with Tom
but and defend Tom that's always like
her fatal flaw yeah but she also then in
private is like Tom yeah you know she I
always respect you she's not like up his
butt yeah so true
I think this people are like those sorts
of like feelings of loyalty towards
someone and just like riding for them
genders no but like a really good show
to have such strong like feelings of you
want to see this person succeed so now
everyone's like buying up her ready to
make cocktails and everyone's trying to
like you know throw their money in
support of Ariana
boycotting Tom Tom and Schwartz and
Sandy's well so that brings me to Tom
Sandoval's statement I have it right
here oh okay so Tom Sandoval was silent
on the matter for you know 24 or 48
hours and then he put out a note that he
wrote saying okay I fully understand and
deserve your anger and disappointment
towards me but please leave Schwartz my
friends and family out of this situation
Schwartz specifically only found out
about this very recently and most
definitely did not condone my actions
this was a very personal thing also
Schwartz and Sandy's might have my name
on it but also there are three other
partners and 20 employees who especially
rely on the restaurant for income from
them and their families just like Tom
Tom I'm all part of a much bigger thing
please direct your anger towards me and
not them they did nothing wrong I'm so
sorry that my partners Greg Braden
Schwartz and our employees have to
suffer for my actions I will be taking a
step back and a Hiatus out of respect
for my employees and partners I need
some time to address everything else
sorry for everything
okay so like tell me all you care about
is money without telling me all you care
about is money like he didn't apologize
to Ariana to his friends like he just
apologized and was like but please like
don't take it out of my stupid [__]
restaurant with a terrible name yeah
it's weird that this statement's not
going to change anything for the people
who are insistent on boycotting his
businesses but it's like when you're a
public figure you get the success of
your business because of your public
Persona like and they're all there for
you when times are good like if they're
in your boat they're in your boat when
it sinks too yeah no it's kind of
delusional I do I do feel bad for that
guy Greg who's clearly like an actual
businessman with experience and
knowledge uh because he was on the
Schwartz and Sandy's Instagram
responding to comments fighting for his
life like I feel bad for him because he
put you know so much of his time money
and energy and into two [__] morons
um and this you know when the pendulum
swings High it swings High you know
Daily Mail party everyone wants to be at
our thing we we don't need to run any
ads and people will be lining out the
door but when the pendulum swings the
other way you know when your whole brand
is like you said build off your public
Persona you have to be able to withstand
that too because that's the business
you're in right and when you make
decisions in your personal life like you
have to know that they can affect your
business because when your business is
your personal life yeah yeah yeah
the statement was trash
um and like trust me I get it like I'm a
business person too like one of my major
concerns at this time would be this
business I just launched but for you
know public perception like my God at
least pretend to give a [__] about
Ariana or like the people you just
stumbled over in your Affair like to
Simply address this dumb [__]
restaurant is he's so he's so calculated
and so kind of um
what's the word I'm looking for uh
he's like he just his intentions are so
obvious and the fact that he didn't even
try and cover it up and and be subtle in
his statement really just proves what
kind of like low life he is well there's
nothing he could say right now
especially right now like so then don't
say anything about Ariana there's no
apology that like anybody wants to hear
like this is going to be like a long
road to Rehabilitation for his image
that and you know an apology on
Instagram's not gonna nobody wants to
hear it right now but I think he thought
that reminding people that there are
people who work for the business that
have families like would
touch people in here yeah but again
that's really not the responsibility of
Bravo fans
yeah it's not
so
that's all we have for him
quiet Raquel like there have been rumors
about Raquel and her crisis PR team on
dumois and what sort of Route they're
taking they say that she's actually
gonna break up with Tom Sandoval which I
think she should not do the only way out
of this is to be together forever yep
no it doesn't remind me at all honestly
it like it does like it was so like and
then remember um Vegas girl like Kristen
just really wanted to prove to everyone
that like yes she's crazy but like Tom
made her crazy like she thinks he
cheated with Ariana he's also cheated
with this Vegas girl like he is a
cheater and I feel as though she's been
enormously Vindicated oh she has been
but I feel like she was for a while and
also in the fact that Tom and Kristen
had a horrible relationship and we saw
that in every episode every single day
and by the time they broke up it was it
was like Hallelujah the fact that there
was someone there for that Tom could
move on with it was like please go like
yeah we would love to see two people
that shouldn't be together not be
together yeah but even though there are
rumors that they were going through a
hard time which I do believe
um you know after 10 years like they he
also has these two restaurants he's put
all of his money into it like he's also
annoying as [__] like I do believe that
relationship wasn't peaking but they
didn't have that like toxic quality like
Tom and Kristen did no it's something
that you work through not like you go
and have an affair with the girl's best
friend I cannot get over this honestly
like and you know what
everyone was like oh what's wrong with
Ariana she didn't want to get married
[__] she better she's probably so
[__] happy yeah that she could just
walk out yeah they share a house
together so it'll be like a little you
know paperwork they don't have to go
through a divorce like she's a queen
she's so smart yeah and I feel like Tom
Sandoval if he's smart but he's not and
he's so egotistical like you would think
he would just like whatever Ariana wants
to do is like what we'll do because any
pushback she gets from him she just all
she needs to do is put on social media
Tom's taking the house no totally and
and
Ariana has been on the show for a really
long time she I'm assuming does really
well financially because she didn't do
anything crazy you know she didn't start
her and Katie are being so smart about
this sandwich shop like looking for
investors not doing anything too hasty
they don't want it to be this huge space
like they're taking it on slowly I feel
like she's been really responsible
financially and Tom when he was talking
about venmoing his bandmates and renting
Studio space I didn't realize like he
had to pay all a thousand dollars a day
to play to pay for Schwartz and Sandy's
right so I'm not open he's in a hole
like he flew his family out and and he
couldn't cancel the flights like he I
feel like he's actually really not doing
well financially and the fact that
they're not married is a huge blessing
for Ariana who I feel like has been
really smart with her Vanderpump money
and she's been on for a long time so
with this rate she can be making less
than thirty thousand dollars an episode
like she's doing really well she's
definitely making way more than that
yeah because she's one of the flashy no
um she started this little side hustle
nothing crazy yeah and even even if she
just cashed her Vanderpump checks like
she's doing really well and it doesn't
seem like she has spending problems that
we know about so I believe she has a
podcast
does she I think
oh my God I could just all I see right
now is like Sheena I don't need to talk
about the store trying to get Ariana on
her podcast let me just look up Ariana
Maddox
no she doesn't sorry oh Earth to Ariana
but it hasn't been updated since
November okay so like
she doesn't do it anymore yeah um
sheena's trying to get the exclusive for
shenanigans please I was I was obsessed
with that whole Saga on the most recent
episodes like sheena's so obvious like
oh my God walking over she by the way I
forget that they keep saying Sheena
lives far Sheena like doesn't live in
L.A she lives by like the marina like
literally 45 minutes away so the fact
that literally in the span of a week she
made like three trips to Tom Schwartz's
apartment one for the pregame one to
hang out with Sandoval and then one to
record the podcast like loser loser like
I cannot get over it I thought like
honestly I know we all treat Tom
Schwartz like this Village Idiot but
like the way he's so easily manipulated
by people like you didn't know what
Sheena was doing and you didn't tell her
hey Sheena cut that part out like he's
so like dumb yeah he's so dumb he just
like doesn't have a spine enough to say
Sheena cut that out uh yeah I did
actually have some respect for him when
he turned Raquel down at the same and he
knew he didn't even think he was filming
he turned her down before yeah wait are
we still filming of course eventually
they do kiss at sheena's wedding but
that is nothing like whenever they will
kiss I'm just gonna be awesome you know
what I'm gonna feel worse for Schwartz
because I'm gonna be like Raquel was
playing him this whole time as a cover
for her fair with Sanibel when she
kisses Schwartz she's having an affair
with Sandoval already so it's like she's
manipulating him and it's like we are
supposed to be mad at shorts but I'm
actually gonna feel sorry for him the
whole schwarzen Raquel thing started
because some rumor got released at
Coachella Tom was kissing
Raquel now a lot of people say like
maybe the rumor got twisted and like Tom
Sandoval was kissing Raquel and like
Schwartz just like went with it like oh
there's a silly rumor about me maybe but
the timeline like doesn't really I know
I know because coachella's in April yeah
yeah
um but my God Sheena like has actually
and this is saying a lot because I feel
like she's looked really bad for many
seasons this might be the worst she's
ever looked
um and now knowing what we know knowing
that she's really isolating herself from
everyone just to support Raquel and now
Raquel is this like radioactive villain
she looks really stupid she still has
Ariana as like Ariana is her first
friend on the show yeah and so for her
to now throw her support behind Ariana
like that is a life raft she can cling
to but it's like when they're all
hanging out at Ariana's house like
Katie's not talking to her
no Helen her like best friend sorry
their kids their daughters are together
every single day they're so so close
well she just looks stupid so it's just
Katie really yeah by the way I'm
obsessed with Katie like she's been so
funny and I love her friendship with
Lala like I know they're like the last
two of that group who are still on the
show like Britney's out and stouti's out
and Kristen's out
um so they like really only have each
other but I feel like their friendship
is really genuine and they're like
really they're in like a similar place
but they're also in really different
places in their lives like sobriety and
motherhood but I feel like they have a
really good friendship and Katie's just
being so funny and honestly I do agree
with pretty much everything Katie has
said thus far like yeah we had this
agreement
fine you want to [__] Raquel I'll run
train through your restaurant like that
was so funny
um and I feel like she's Justified I
know a lot of people are like you're
divorced but like asking just not to dip
in the friends group like is really not
asking a lot unless it's the love of
your life
it's not asking a lot and especially
it's definitely not the like even if it
is the love of your life you don't go
around to love if you're like hey want
to make out let's make out I feel like
it's high school it's high school it's
so disrespectful the fact that a friend
of hers would be the one to come up with
the idea and sort of force them together
and do all these like
nefarious behind the scenes things and
act like no I just want to have a
pre-game so she'd have to go alone like
shut up no shut up and like I guess
Katie did say that thing in Vegas
because Katie didn't deny it she just
said like I said it but like I don't
feel that way anymore like honestly
respect that's like the most relatable
[__] thing like yeah I said that and
I don't mean it because I was like
pretending to be mature or whatever but
like I'm not yeah when I was watching
this most recent episode and like Katie
eventually like brings Christina Kelly
along I was thinking like how miserable
filming The Show Must Be for Katie she
doesn't have any of her friends that she
started with it's now all about these
new people and the new people are just
like now going after Schwartz like what
the [__] what am I doing here because if
she just didn't have to hang out with
this group of people anymore like she
wouldn't have if Schwartz goes and makes
out with Raquel it's not a problem but
she's one of three original cast members
on the show still she's making more
money than all those other people that's
not a check you just walk away from no
she has to keep showing up and keep
being miserable and keep watching Tom
Sandoval on the most extras and keep
hearing DJ James Kennedy spinning on the
ones and twos no but you know what say
what you want about DJ James Kennedy but
I love him yeah like first of all he's
so unapologetically himself that like
you actually have to respect it he's an
amazing reality star like he really is
and he's done and said some horrible
unforgivable things but there's
something about him like you just keep
coming back to and with his DJ career
like everyone made fun of him when he
first started but you know what like he
turned that see you next Tuesday thing
into a legitimate Affair at sir he does
like a really good job and you know what
when Tom Sandoval is like we're so lucky
to have DJ James Kennedy opening for us
like he was right like your band is a
[__] joke you can't [__] sing and
you know what I've actually seen GJ
jumps Kennedy DJ and he's pretty [__]
great no and it's a great time it's a
great idea like I feel like a few people
from the show have made like uh IRL
things happen for themselves like sassy
and her and her podcast and her book and
like she had so much success and like
James did that with his DJ career not
only does he DJ within the restaurants
beautiful but he could go DJ at a club
and like all these Vanderpump fans are
going to come to want to see him like
it's so smart everybody keeps trying to
do stuff like that even the restaurants
like TomTom like that was a success but
it's not a shoe-in and I was just saying
to Zach Zach just started watching
Vanderpump again like this season I
don't know why and we were talking about
James and I was like yeah but I love him
he was like what I was like there's just
something so funny about him like so
real even when when he's wrong he's so
wrong and it's annoying but when he's
right he's so right and he doesn't back
out and it's like yes thank you go off
no and he's like funny like he's like
funny and just like he's himself now I
would never want to date him in my whole
life could never be his girlfriend I
don't think he should be drinking but
there's like a lovable affable sigh to
him that I appreciate and he's a great
person on a reality show who has more
than you would expect right moments
yeah yeah no he just gets like we're so
blinded by his like dumb [__] like when
he just says things about with like
Katie's body like you were just blinded
by that but every now and then like he
does
he does have uh he has his moments yeah
and he's just funny he's like I don't
want to say the s word or the d word
stupid
he's so funny
um and now James and Katie are an
alliance and I'm sorry it's not it's an
Unstoppable Force I don't think they
should be together but like the two of
them I would not want them as my enemies
no
I am obsessed like this stuff that has
been coming out like the memes like
it's so
it is actually reinvigorated my love for
this show yeah I was feeling so fatigued
by these characters and these story
lines and these plots but now I thought
I thought Raquel and Schwartz just
making out was [__] crazy like right
and that was okay we have a season
because they're gonna kiss right this we
have a franchise we have a decade
it's too much I mean you could have said
the same thing about Jen Shaw so let's
not oh that's true these kids Pizza Pros
they don't these kids are Pros the The
Real Housewives of Salt Lake City are
all rookies they don't know like they
were ill-equipped these kids are not
they know they've seen what the power of
this show can do yeah and honestly a lot
of it a lot of them are in so deep with
their restaurants and their businesses
they are not about to let this this ship
go down without a fight no and now they
have
yeah they're not gonna [__] this up I
have literally the utmost faith in them
but to be honest I would love in this
very moment to hear from some of our
former disgrace cast members Jax of
course you know people are saying like
out of all everyone on the cast like Jax
turned out to be the upstanding guy the
good husband the father
yeah who'da thunk like he would have
really kind of nestled into his life
after pump rules in such a respectable
way he doesn't thirst out live tweeting
the episodes like he's totally out of it
him and Brittany look so happy they both
look really good I would love to hear
from them yep Stasi too how dare because
she has him the most yeah and you know
what
she was right and of course Kristen of
course I mean and Kristen being the
bigger person you know going over to
Ariana's and being there for her posting
team Ariana like a lot of girls wouldn't
do that like a lot of girls would still
be holding on to a lot of the anger and
resentment they have for their their
ex's new girl but they've been friends
for a while I think Justin you know she
especially season now like dodge a
bullet thanks Ariana
I mean how anyone and not to be mean
like how anyone could even be remotely
attracted to Tom Sandoval and I don't
mean that in a physical sense I mean his
personality his midlife crisis his band
like I don't know how you could see
someone on stage and then be like yeah I
want to have sex with that like he's so
cringe like the Schwartz's mom he's so
like the Schwartz's mom you know who he
reminds me of
with like the Bravo fans like these
older women who like love him it reminds
me of Hugh Grant in um music and lyrics
like before he blows back up again he
like plays county fairs and there's like
five like 50 year old women who were
obsessed with his band back in the 80s
like it's it's really it's it's pathetic
yeah but people like that's the show and
people really
do like did like him and like go to his
shows and like oh my God he's singing
about shorts his mom that's so funny
it's it's not though and so we need to
as a society discuss why we ever thought
that was funny no no I didn't know
people did like there was an audience
for that and like that's actually the
real problem I want to interview the
audience members so I know are you
genuinely laughing or like it's like
laughing because you felt bad because
like that I understand were you in extra
like for the show did you buy a ticket
no and like the way he named his band
like Tom's animals and the most extra
because like somebody called him extra
like two seasons ago and he's like
trying to make a moment out of it like
there are ways to take things people
have said about you on the show and like
turn it into your own brand and I think
people have done it really successfully
but when you try and it like doesn't
catch on and like it's like a flop and
you're trying so hard there's honestly
nothing more about her saying and just
like Ariana was so good to him even if
they weren't you know
physically like together anymore but
like when he's trying on all those
outfits for his friends she's taking him
seriously being like no well it's good
but like what else and then be like yes
that's it like could never be me no I
would literally sit there and be like
I'm gonna be real with you you look like
a [__] clown like no but she was
blindly supportive and he so did not
deserve that and I really feel bad for
Ariana but I also I'm excited we're
gonna get like this Genesis this Rebirth
of Ariana where like the fans are 100
behind her she's single she looks great
like I'm ready yeah
this is so crazy and honestly I feel
like she's gonna keep the house I feel
like she can I feel like she can too but
does she want to does she want a big
house she doesn't seem like the type I
feel like she's kind of like a penthouse
girl yeah like a downtown condo she
doesn't want to be in the suburbs alone
we're literally reverting to like the
Vanderpump of yore like yeah they were
all in these apartments that had like
you know no furniture and they were just
like these young kids with no money and
then they all got like a little too rich
they bought houses whatever but then
they all started going through divorce
and restaurants and honestly a lot of
them have no money no they have money
but you don't need a house when you
don't have a like a family have a home
right right like a but yeah I don't like
them too Tom Schwartz is in an apartment
now I think Sheena lives in an apartment
I think Lala does
um it's not a financial thing Katie yeah
now maybe Ariana but it's not a
financial thing it's like you don't need
a a home when you're a single person
like that who wants that right no it's
also just like wait are you dare not to
have to be in like a residential family
neighborhood when like now you want to
go out all the time and you want to be
closer to bars and restaurants and you
want to be able to Uber like you don't
need to go all the like 30 minutes yeah
no honestly like when they all moved
into houses and like Brittany and Jax
were talking about how it's like it's
not as great as it looks like Jax was
mowing the yard like that was funny yeah
but pretty and Jacks are still there
well and they should be like they have a
kid and they're settled like they're not
going out they're just like keeping
their heads down and like growing their
family yeah so they need a house right
no but we're reverting to the Vanderpump
of your yeah everyone in these
apartments that are like gross
they don't have to be gross no but like
that's what it was that's what it was
but they're not going to be gross like
Katie's not no no Rosa Park no not Katie
no no not Ariana
no not Ariana I wonder if she'll keep
the house we'll have to wait and say
yeah
it's just been
it's been a time yeah they're gonna have
to speed up these episodes and also if
I'm the editors I'm combing through this
footage to see if this moments that I
missed yep because that's what
everything through that's what
everyone's doing now like they're going
through sheena's Vlogs and people's old
stories like just to see you know if
there was something we missed I feel
like the editors could maybe find
something that they didn't care about
and just maybe shift the focus a little
bit of the rest of the season otherwise
it's going to be Dreadful to watch until
we get to this part but it will be worth
it because cameras are up yep and then
there's a reunion yep and everyone will
be answering for their sins the reunion
is like my my next Super Bowl yeah but I
think it's also important to remember
that this is a television show and yet
you don't know these people and we can
talk about it for entertainment value
and but then like I don't need to go and
leave mean comments on anyone's page
like I like I don't know you you didn't
betray me like we are just fans and
Spectators like
calm the [__] down yeah you know because
it's like people are not meant to
deal with receive and see and deal with
this much criticism about themselves no
matter what their crime is unless it's
murdering your Alex Murdock yeah
so just keep that in mind keep a level
ahead you guys yeah
are you ready for our next story if it's
the next story that's brought to you by
Squarespace is it it is
all right you guys whether you're
starting a side business you work in
e-commerce Squarespace is an amazing
place to get started with all of their
online tools so from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful presence online and
run your business
so
I have built a lot of websites in my day
and I feel like it can be really
intimidating whether you know you have
any experience doing like software
engineering or website building and
Squarespace is an amazing place to start
because they'll help you design a
website they'll help you get your domain
and it's really it's for dummies like
you don't need a degree in computer
science they have amazing different
features
um like email campaigns you can collect
donations you can share on social media
they'll give you really powerful
insights into your analytics like who's
visiting your site how long they're
interacting
um you'll get in-depth website analytics
like page views traffic sources Etc
um also if you're blogging they are
blogging platform supports a
configurable share button lets your
visitors share content on Facebook
Twitter Google Plus all the places so
whatever you're building a website for
whether that's e-commerce blogging
showcasing your photography Squarespace
is a fabulous place to start check out
squarespace.com toast for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch use our
offer code toast to save 10 off your
first purchase of a website or a domain
so again that's squarespace.com toast
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch use offer code toast to save
10 off your first purchase of a website
or a domain today's episode is also
brought to you by Jenny Kane you are in
for a treat because support for today's
episode comes directly from Jenny Kane
think minimalist meets luxury Jenny Kane
items are classic comfortable and
California inspired from the cashmere or
cotton knit sweater you're obsessed with
to the flowy summer dress you never want
to take off with elevated everyday
Basics and wardrobe Essentials getting
dressed is easier than ever before when
it comes to investing in an outfit
that'll last we choose Jenny Kane for
limited time our listeners are getting
15 off their entire order when you go to
Jenny kane.com use the code toast to get
15 off all right let's talk Jenny Kane I
have so many items in my home from Jenny
Kane home I have so many items in my
wardrobe from Jenny Kane their cashmere
sweaters are that [__] like they are
really really high quality I feel like
it's really good to invest in like a few
key pieces that you can have for a
really long time I have a cardigan I
have a pullover actually that I stole
from you it's a v-neck kind of like tan
gorgeous like Coastal grandmother Jenny
Kane is like the coastal grandmother
Bible their sweaters are the it item you
will get so many compliments their
everyday sweater their striped Chloe
crewneck sweater their Cardigans are
made so you can feel the difference it's
the high-end necklace that you could
wear on repeat because it goes with so
many things so they're known for their
staple cashmere sweaters so they're best
selling cocoon cardigan which I have
it's Ultra cozy a relaxed fit and if you
haven't tried their mules or sandals you
haven't felt true Comfort Jenny Kane
believes in one thing the art of
Simplicity with a focus on Comfort
quality and Timeless design find your
Forever pieces at jennycane.com our
listeners get 15 off your first order
when you use code toast at checkout
that's 15 off your first order at
j-e-n-n-i-k-a-y-n-e.com promo code toast
the brand go to for All Season Staples
treat yourself because you deserve it
thank you Claudia you're welcome our
next story Chris Rock did his live
Netflix comedy special selective outrage
and he's mentioning it all he shredded
Will Smith with Oscar slap Joe slap joke
said quote everyone calls him a [__]
and who does he hit me almost a year
after the infamous Oscar slap comedian
Chris Rock finally addressed what
happened in his live Netflix special
after an hour of new material that only
alluded to slap gate he said in the
beginning he said quote they say words
hurt anybody who says words hurt has
never been punched in the face so I was
at the top of the show he didn't get
back into the slap or anything I thought
that was kind of gonna be it
um but no he did like a whole five to
ten minutes going in on what happened he
said quote you all know what happened to
me getting smacked by Suge Smith
everybody knows everybody [__] knows
I got smacked like a year ago and people
are like did it hurt it still hurts I
got summertime ringing in my ears
despite the pressure from the press to
open up about what happened he's adamant
that he won't be dissecting it on a talk
show he said quote I'm not a victim baby
you will never see me on Oprah or Gail
crying you will never see it it's never
going to happen [__] that [__] I took
that [__] like Pacquiao you know I
thought that was a really good response
one because it harked back to like a big
segment he did in his special about how
everyone is a victim these days we're
always saying that like searching for
victimhood everyone wants to be a victim
um but also it was a nice little dig at
Will Smith because like Will Smith got
up there and slapped [__] Chris Rock
and then Will Smith went on Ted table
talk 400 times and cried like making
himself the victim so I like how Chris
Rock not only like harked back to
previous material but he was also like
I'm not a victim even though technically
like in this Saga like he was the victim
of his lab like you're gonna go and cry
okay [__] like I'm gonna stand up here
and make jokes about it yeah I love to
table talk but um
by the way he really went hard I
honestly thought he like wouldn't want
to be associated with this anymore and
like he was kind of using it for click
bait for his special like I honestly
didn't know if he was still like angry
or if he was ever really angry but he's
[__] mad and you know what he called
Will Smith a [__] he called Jada
Pinkett Smith a predator which honestly
it's a pretty decent call because I
didn't really put together that that
dumb entanglement thing was with one of
her son's friends like that's [__]
weird and I also didn't know that like
beyond the slap like beyond the surface
there's actually history with Jada will
and Chris as it pertains to the Oscars
like Jada was really upset when Chris
Rock agreed to host it all those years
ago because
will wasn't nominated was it nominated
and so I didn't realize that it was
layered beyond that so he was like he
was digging yeah at Jada like he was you
know he was starting stuff with that
joke GI Jane but because there was
history there yeah and now but no
because he was slapped hosts and
presenters like make lots of little
jokes at people like yeah a slap
for a joke it doesn't even matter like
Chris could have said the most
disgusting joke of all time and it still
wouldn't have warranted a slap like you
don't [__] slap people right and so
now he's going in on them and what
happened and how I guess Chris even
called him when everything like went
down with the entanglement like and to
like be there for him and instead he
slaps him and it's like everybody was
talking [__] about Will Smith and like
clowning on him
but that's who he slaps and also he
talks about how Will Smith is so much
bigger than him like they're not the
same size they're it's not a fair fight
like he's a big guy and his slap [__]
hurts yeah honestly like I I was almost
prepared to be disappointed because I
feel like Chris I just thought Chris
Rock would have been like moved on from
it and like he's like we're good just
like above it yeah and I'm so glad he
wasn't because you know what you got
[__] slapped and sometimes you just
need to go for the jugular yeah I don't
know why I thought he would
like not be as mad as he is yeah no me
too like I don't know why I kind of I
just perceive him maybe it's because
he's like this comedy Legend as someone
who's just like above [__] like this but
you know what like Will Smith dragged
him down to the trenches and Chris Rock
is joining him and I respect that like I
hate that [__] like rise above no
couldn't be me
still is above it because he's not
getting physical he's using his words
right right like a grown up I was
actually really pleased with the
response like he's mad and you know what
that's a human response yeah and like he
took a year to set to figure out what he
wanted to say when he wanted to say it
how he wanted to say it and like there's
nothing rash about this and I also
appreciate that he's saying it all he's
mentioning it all and he's mentioning
the entanglement and all the things I
could have said about Will Smith but I
didn't but I wrote now no it's true like
him and Jada really like for many years
like dragged their relationship in the
public sphere it's not like they were
being dragged they put themselves there
they kind of like embarrass themselves
and their families over and over so when
you think of the birth of not birth is
it breath breath breadth of material
that you could write about these two
really GI Jane
is is harmless and I know like she has
alopecia so I get why it's layered but
to be honest the rationale for why the
joke might have been insensitive is
irrelevant now because you got up and
slapped someone like to me I don't give
a [__] what you have to say I don't care
about your victimhood you are wrong in
perpetuity because you slap someone yeah
and I feel like for the last year like
Will Smith has been dipping his toe in
his PR
cycle you know
and now will uh Chris Rock just like
back down again start again start
because obviously I had forgotten and
whatever but I thought like Chris was
over it so I'm over it right now we're
reliving it like Chris is like such a
cutie you know we came on that special
he's like this family man like talking
about his kids he's so cute he was so
funny he made some really good points I
was enjoying the special and I'm like
you know what now I'm feeling protective
again of Chris Rock and he's mad so I'm
mad it's all it's starting all over
again which must be really infuriating
for Will Smith anything he did in the
last year to try and overcome it we're
back at square one a hundred percent and
you know what I love that Chris like
didn't give an interview and he saved
this moment for himself I'm sure he sold
the [__] out of the special not only
because it was you know the first time
he was talking about Will Smith but it
was also this technological Marvel of
live streaming on Netflix I love that he
kept it for himself it's like you know
us doing it on the patreon 100 plus I
love that so and they invest in comedy
at Netflix like he probably got paid so
much I I
I can't imagine he got paid less than 20
million dollars for one special one live
yeah it's possible that this was a part
of like a three special deal like yeah
they like to do that three specials for
60. so but this is different you know
it's live live television people Chris
Rock it's Chris Rock live show it's
Chris Rock Live
Chrissy Rock would be better because
it's 30 Rock Chrissy Rock
okay see no too many syllables somehow
30. Chrissy I know but it's they don't
say 30 Rock they say live show it's
certainly that's 30 Rock lives
oh it's crazy Rock live show yeah it's
literally perfect it felt this is just
as good the way I was singing it
um
the special otherwise was good it wasn't
like amazing but it was really good and
funny Oh I thought it was really strong
I thought he made some really good
points some really good jokes oh my God
I was telling you how I was I can't
remember the last time I laughed so hard
at a joke from a comedy special is when
he was talking about the difference
between dating financially the
difference financially between dating
older women and younger women and when
he said for an older woman you have to
pay for a younger woman she'll be like I
want shoes give me one pair of shoes
shoes
and then for an older woman she's like
can you fix my roof it was really funny
oh my God honestly I couldn't even hear
the next five minutes because I
literally if I was further along my
pregnancy I think I would have given
birth Zach and I were
I thought it was funny I didn't think it
was like tears funny
I was just waiting to see what he was
gonna say like what does an older woman
want a house like I didn't know and she
wants you to fix her roof like it was so
he's also making headlines for his bit
about Meghan Markle which I thought was
really interesting so let's talk about
that and then that's actually going to
lead into our next story
um so he had a bit about the ways that
it was the same it was the same bit we
were talking about earlier like just
victimhood like everyone once but he was
the same of something that America were
addicted to attention there's four ways
to get attention you know uh you could
be put your ass on Instagram your ass
out you could be Infamous you could be
excellent mm-hmm or Serena Williams be a
victim right and he said and speaking of
you know Meghan Markle and her journey
to victimhood and everything that she
shared and he's talked about you know
how she like the things that she said on
Oprah and how uh you know you didn't
know the royal family was racist like
they invented racism and then he started
talking about a few of the things that
she said to you know uh exhibit how they
were racist and he was like that's not
racism that's like in-law [__] right
right
so it was just really funny and she
doesn't get really any negative negative
press in the US aside from that South
Park thing that was a few weeks ago
which we heard that they didn't like and
that uh they were upset about but then
we heard that no they didn't care
so I feel like to go from like being you
know so celebrated and not and no one
will say a bad word to that South Park
episode and then this which is like the
one of the biggest comedy moments this
year and he's like really going in on
them
um there must not be happy
to be honest it was it was refreshing
because I feel like what comedy is
really supposed to do is be the thing
you think but don't say and we exist in
a culture and I think it's out of a
protectiveness for Megan which I
appreciate I think it started from a
good place but you really can't
criticize Harry and Megan without being
you know labeled as something and so for
Chris Rock to get on here and just kind
of say the thing we were all thinking
like I don't know some of the stuff they
described like is it evil no is it like
do I deal with the same [__] with my
in-laws kind of like it's it was
refreshing to hear and that's really
what comedy is supposed to be and so to
hear someone who probably has a lot to
lose by saying that I'm sure he could
hobnob with Harry and Megan at Island's
house whenever he wants I don't know
that that's a lot to lose though not
getting the invite no but I'm saying
like he could run into Harry and Megan
tomorrow like honestly like him saying
that is brave it's not like some nobody
comic on a pod agree but he does I don't
think he there's a lot to lose
by not being able to run into them and
it being awkward you know what I mean
like I think it's worse himself in a bad
position like he's he's on the same
level of Fame yeah so he puts himself
kind of
and perhaps as a Target or or putting
himself in a bad spot and for him to say
it means he really believes it and I
think a lot of people in the audience
agreed with it and I think people
watching at home is like well yeah like
I mean we all think that but nobody say
it yeah that's what comedy so that's the
purpose of Comedy yeah but I feel like
the more time that they spend in
Hollywood I'm constantly shocked by how
few friends it seems that they have and
Rebel Wilson Rebel Wilson is our next
story but have a few things that they
should be at that they're not at
Michaela when you zoom out it's like why
aren't they spotted at dinner with this
and that and them and them like we never
hear that the only really things that we
see won the Ellen party which we
reference every single time we say where
you could see them yep and in the
documentary the people who called her
after the opening Beyonce called her
yeah does she text with Beyonce today
right no they it's almost like well why
do they even live in LA
yeah but like they're not at the mecca
they're not at like some of these big
birthday parties for some of the really
big stars like
I don't know if Hollywood's going how
they thought it was going to go that's a
good point and a good segue to our next
straight because that's really
interesting I don't know why they
wouldn't be embraced by Hollywood
um because it seems like right after
they left the family they were they
Oprah went well and everything
um but Rebel Wilson was about on Watch
What Happens Live talking about meeting
Harry and Megan and while she said
really sweet things about Harry she said
Megan was not naturally warm
so that's so funny because that's what
Megan said about Kate
oh that is funny that is and I feel like
Megan's
brand that she posts for if there's just
like this warm the warm American hugger
you know right right right
Rebel Wilson says she did not get a warm
reception from Megan when she first met
that it was just of Sussex she said
Megan was not as cool she wasn't as
naturally warm however she noted that
Marco could have been standoffish uh due
to her mom her Australian Mom asking
slightly rude questions like where are
your kids Rebel said that is [__]
rude don't ask her that they said they
met because they had a mutual friend
um and Harry was really warm and sweet
and that Megan was not the way that
Harry was and she didn't mince words
yeah
I was surprised for her to be like so
direct and like shady and I feel like
actually like Rebel has more to lose
saying just this about Megan and Harry
she's not on the same level as Chris
Rock where it's like Chris Rock is a
legend period doesn't matter who he
offends yeah
I was really surprised yes me too but I
also feel like we're always saying here
like okay one referencing one time
meeting someone like isn't a fair
assessment of their character like maybe
she had a long day maybe she was in a
bad mood maybe she felt awkward maybe
she doesn't like Rebel Wilson like maybe
she heard Rebel Wilson say something
about her you know what I mean like I
don't feel like it's actually an
accurate but I'm adding it just it's
noted
but I'm not gonna make a general uh
not observation General I'm having a
hard time with the words today
General like
judgment judgment sure on one person's
one time it's not like Megan's um
I can't talk Rebel said oh every time
I've met Megan she's been a [__] like
it was one time and you know what
um it's noted but I'm not making any big
any big statements yet I'll say two
things about that one we say this all
the time I hate when people on Tick Tock
are like so-and-so was rude and they
like have these anecdotal reasons as to
why they're rude and they don't even
tell you who it is but I feel like the
fact that she said this and it seemed
like she said in the commercial break
and then repeated it yes because she
said we were just talking about this in
the break so she repeated it again on
television the fact that she would say
it was her not just like oh ice I hobnob
was someone who you would think was so
warm but really it wasn't Anonymous she
would say it was her she would not be
like but maybe actually did she did say
maybe she did but my mom asking rude
questions I don't think it's so weird to
say where are your kids if I'm out in
some like someone said where's Harry I
just think that not rude just dumb like
he's home what do you think no it
depends like who you are like if you're
easily offended and you're like are you
judging my mother also depends on what
the uh context where we are like if
we're in the park having a picnic like
where are your kids like they can they
be here but we had a cocktail party at a
dinner party where are my kids like
they're asleep when she lives right
there with the setter sitter yeah like
so it depends on the context I don't
think it's like like overall the rudest
question
um
the fact that she like just didn't mince
words I I'm
no I find it I I found the whole thing
extremely interesting yeah especially
since that like Harry's supposed to be
like the British stiff upper lip and
she's right the warm American American
and we got the opposite so I thought
that was interesting no I just also
appreciate when people share their
anecdotes like I'm always wondering
what's going on behind closed doors yeah
no one no one like shares stuff like
this so about any no I know like they're
very just direct and honest I feel like
Rebel must have had like a really nasty
experience with her it must have been
to then just say not naturally warm no
it wasn't just like an unnatural warmth
that she felt the need to share it must
have been worse yeah it's not a good
month for Harry and Megan I feel like
actually hasn't been a good few months I
don't think the reception to the book
and the documentary was really what they
thought the book reception was better
but the documentary reception was not
great
um but the book sales were great so yeah
they have like a lot of money but he
already got paid the 20 million for
three books so they already cashed those
checks I think they care just about
public perception and image as they do
about money yes but they have to care
about both yeah like like you can't have
long term you can't have one without the
other and they need both it's not like
they're part of the family anymore the
family just gets to worry about public
perception so true
worry about those things while also
trying to make money yeah like parallel
to the money yeah and people like you
know when you do stuff for money they
judge you as like what did you sell for
that
right I'm gonna [__] judge you yeah
yeah no it has been a great like six
months honestly yeah they need to lay
low there nobody they've been laying low
except they went to dinner the other
night no dinner doesn't count I mean put
Harry just did another sit-down
interview mental health like oh my God
the trauma expert like that disaster
opening up their legs for us like it's
enough they need nobody ever regretted
laying low agreed aside from that
interview which he I feel like he does
all these interviews and like just
anybody [__] watch him because I only
like see them the excerpts yeah but
anyways they went to dinner of course
they're allowed to go to dinner but it
was like you know Paparazzi were there
honestly I feel like those moments
actually are in the plus column for me
because they look really happy she
always looks stunning I actually love
seeing but that's not laying low
why no you're allowed to go to dinner
I'm talking about money going to dinner
to eat a meal and going to dinner we're
going to San Vicente Bungalows and the
paparazzi have been called that stuff
doesn't bother me for me it was like the
weeks and months of promo for the
documentary promo for the book sit down
interviews 60 Minutes BBC everything now
this trauma expert like that for people
who really left for for their mental
health and for privacy Stop close your
legs to married men like stop that [__]
bothers me actually the paparazzi
samachande Bungalows like that's what I
expected that's what I was like oh yes
they're coming to Hollywood let's see
the glamor get out of the car what are
you wearing she loves a good coat like
that is exciting yeah that is what I
want to say and they don't do a lot of
that not even they could go to dinner
and call the propriety whenever they
want but like they're but they don't do
it a lot big parties are not at these
big events they could be at the Oscars
presenting they're not and by the way
that type of thirst would actually be
good that's an elevated search glamor
and that's Hollywood what I'm saying is
like what's surprising about their role
in Hollywood is it's not the role I
would have thought that they would have
leaving the royal family and being like
the a-listers that they are right and it
appears as though it's not a choice
because if they were choosing not to be
Hollywood glamor then they wouldn't be
doing all these sit-down interviews so
it's not that they don't want to be in
the spotlight because they do but
they're choosing the most bizarre
spotlights no and the ones that are the
big spotlights are seemingly not
available to them
like I don't know you know yeah I don't
know because they would do it like why
aren't they going to uh they should be
going to the Vanity Fair Oscar party
this year yeah they should be going to
the Oscars they could be presenting at
the Oscars and it could be like a you
know a charitable award something even
though our yes right same for the
Grammys and all the other crap we just
watched and the right where they bring
like elected officials yeah in the same
way that like they're just like
humanitarians okay you know what they've
been like out and about like very public
I would be very interested if they do
anything at the Oscars okay maybe not
presenting but showing up at that Vanity
Fair party for a photo that would be
interesting but then to me the idea that
they couldn't get invited to the Vanity
Fair Oscar party it sounds absurd of
course they could right so is it a
choice
I don't know
but there's like I don't know
we'll see so
are you ready for our next story what
number is this for
four all right
Pete Davidson and his girlfriend chaseee
wonders crash their car into Beverly
Hills home I saw this is a very
nefarious spelling story Pete Davidson
and his girlfriend Chase sui wonders
crashed the car into a Beverly Hills
home Saturday night please confirm to
the post the SNL Alum had been driving a
Mercedes-Benz at a high rate of speed
around 11 pm when he jumped a curb in
the flats neighborhood he reportedly
also hit a fire hydrant and skidded
across the front lawn before slamming
into the corner of the house the siding
on one corner of the home was broken and
pushed inward according to photos of the
damage obtained by TMZ
Beverly Hills please confirm to the post
that the car crash had occurred in
damaged city property the fire hydrant
and that it was in fact Pete behind the
wheel a police spokesperson refused to
provide further details as the
Department's investigation is ongoing
both of them walked away unharmed
or what about the people in the house
people in the house are fine no no no
injuries or anything late night driving
fast residential neighborhood this
doesn't smell good to me no this is no
bueno and you know what
bad decision making and it bad the
preliminary view according to TMZ is
that drugs and alcohol were not involved
here but an investigation is currently
underway
I mean a perfect luminary view like they
can do a blood alcohol test on him when
they
arrive
um as far as weed how do you test for
that
you test like a drug test like normal
okay so maybe I don't know but by the
way like he's gonna have weed in his
system
can you you can't be high and drive
really good question I feel like you can
no way I mean I feel people do but like
I don't know what the levels of
[__] up right but like weed stays in
your system I think for 30 days you take
a drug test it's like yeah well I smoke
weed no but it's like if you take it on
site there's got to be a way like
literally we're sending people to the
Mars like you can find I don't know how
high someone is how do you though
seriously like jump a curb hit a fire
hydrant and drive into someone's house
if you're not even the slightest bit
impaired yeah unless you have like a
medical unless you have a heartstroke
right but they seem they were fine at
the scene right
um
you know
this is fishy for sure nefarious
behavior and I don't want to make any
judgments until
it's Judgment day but
this is terrible yeah I'm glad they're
both okay I'm glad everyone in the house
is okay but now we need to get down to
the bottom of it because it sounds like
it sounds like Pete is making some bad
decisions yeah
and that worries me because he's a good
boy
maybe spending too much time in L.A he's
got to go back to Staten Island you know
those hedonistic Los Angeles yeah
Los Angeles
Los angelinos so we'll keep you posted
on that because I do want to know what
happened here because it's very
concerning 100 are you ready for our
next story is it the last story that's
brought to you by canva it is creating
visual content is an essential part of
what we do here but the creative process
hasn't always been so easy all you have
to do is scroll down to our Instagrams
of your and see some of the turnt
Graphics we used to churn out before we
started using canva for all of our needs
whenever we have guest cards or Graphics
everything we make for social we make on
canva and we found Canada for canva for
teams it has been so easy to collaborate
and design with our team which makes the
whole process so much more creative and
fun so canva for teams is a design
platform that makes it easy for anyone
to create stunning content in any format
from social media posts to videos
presentations websites the endless
templates and premium fonts photos
graphics and videos ad personality and
Edge to our team's content I have to say
Ben introduced us to canva because he
used to use it back when he was like
working at corporate agencies and he was
like it's the best it's the best and
really he revitalized our brand and for
us a creative directed our brand and
when you use canva for teams they make
it easy to maintain your aesthetic add
your own logos fonts colors anything
that you want to create
so um they streamline how you can use
social social media too you can plan
create and share social media content
directly to all of your channels from
one place and even post uh schedule
posts ahead of time so collaborate with
your canva with your team with canva for
teams right now you can get a free
45-day extended trial when you go to
canva dot me slash toast that's
c-a-n-v-a dot m e slash toast for a free
45-day extended trial canva dot me slash
toast
thank you our fifth and final story some
nostalgic but also forward-thinking news
Miley Cyrus is teaming up with Disney
again for Endless Summer Vacation
concert special Miley Cyrus announced on
Friday that she is re-teaming with
Disney for a new concert special the
former Hannah Montana star will perform
her number one single flowers plus seven
other songs from her upcoming album
Endless Summer vacation for the latest
installment of her backyard sessions
additionally the setlist will include
one of her chart topping Classics The
Climb as well as a collaboration with
Rufus Wainwright according to a press
release obtained by Page Six the special
which is interspersed with new interview
footage premieres March 10th at 1pm
Eastern Time on Disney plus the same day
that her LP drops okay like Miley giving
us backyard sessions if you remember the
OG backyard sessions like it was kind of
this like transitional period for Miley
it was like before her solo career
really took off after she like left
Hannah Montana Forever she was just like
this you know Down Home Country
All-American Girl and she like was just
posting these YouTube videos of her
singing in her backyard with like an
accompaniment maybe like a drummer and a
guitarist and it was like these really
high quality videos her I think most
popular one is Jolene she that was like
her iconic long brown hair era and like
boho bun she wore a bun on that one
um it was so like we were so obsessed
with Miley at that point and Hannah
Montana ended and like we really didn't
know what the future held I believe
maybe she had released Party in the USA
but we were like we were
literally desperate for anything Miley
could give us and what she gave us was
the backyard sessions and they became so
iconic and she didn't even do that many
because then her solo career really took
off and she didn't have to slum it in
her backyard for YouTube anymore
and her sound changed a little bit then
she was with bangers and like that's not
like an acoustic backyard Vibe because
she's constantly changing evolving
but the way that she knows how much
those meant to us and she's bringing it
like I'm deeply moved this is so
thoughtful it is they wear a cultural
reset for sure and they continue to have
impact like people are still watching
them people are still talking about them
you know I'm sure they're on Tick Tock
clipped all the time and she's bringing
it back and the fact that she's bringing
it back with Disney plus just like
all's well and that's good it's really
full circle you know because she could
have gone to any streamer and if she had
such negative feelings about Disney it
would not be Disney yep but this like
just hopes to show like we're okay
everything was okay Hannah was good I'm
okay with everything
here's the backyard sessions
no you're right I'm actually getting
like choked up this is really beautiful
yeah she's going back to her roots and
she's singing The Climb 2023 Edition
I'm so excited she sings The Climb quite
frequently and she never does a bad job
and she always adds like something new a
little twang a new note a new pitch she
really always does that song Justice and
the way she like protects that song for
us is actually really sweet like that
song means so much to so many of her
fans and I think you know a lot of
people were always talking about how
they you know they kind of shy away from
the thing and no matter how big Miley
gets like people will always want to go
to her concerts and and hear the climb
and she always leaves that opportunity
like that potential possibility for us
and she always does the song Justice and
like I really want to thank her for that
because she loves the song and she knows
that we love it and like the fact that
she loves it makes us love it more no
and I think that we love this song so
much but there are so many things from
like you know back in the day that you
would love just because of the Nostalgia
but I think coincidentally like the
climb is an absolutely beautiful song
and the lyrics and the message are
eternal and so she's not like
embarrassed by it it's not like the
Jonas Brothers going and singing Year
3000 which is just a gimmick like this
is a girl yeah this is a song that like
means something it's a beautiful song
it's something that could be released
today and it's just like a gorgeous song
it's not just because we're not asking
her to perform Best of Both Worlds you
know right no it's it's
like a real song but the fact that she
can even see through all the Hannah
stuff to be like oh that is a real
beautiful song that just happened to
fall into my lap as Hannah just it shows
a maturity on her part not to shun
everything from Hannah as like corny bad
Disney nonsense no you're right the
message is really Evergreen
Evergreen Life's a climb there's always
going to be another Mountain that's not
even the lyrics
no I know but that's like the message of
the song what's inspired her the message
is there's always going to be another
Mountain period I'm always going to want
to make it move always gonna be an
uphill battle sometimes I'm gonna have
to lose ain't about how fast I get there
damn straight ain't about what's waiting
on the other side facts it's the climb
tax straight facts no lies we're told
zero absolutely none
and that's a message we could all use
every day in every way
Jackie
that's beautiful
it's the clock
I'm so good I won't I won't
I won't spiral but like I could you
could
when those violence come in she better
have a full string Orchestra Orchestra
in the backyard session or else we're
gonna have problems
sometimes you gotta have to laugh
and about how fast such a good song
ain't about what's waiting on the other
side
it's the class
keep on moving keep climbing
keep the faith baby
[Music]
it's all about it's all about the climb
this would be like me singing Don't Rain
on My Parade like it's just her oh oh I
can't sing The Climb like not on this
show no
Jesus that's where I almost put my steak
in the ground I'm so glad you brought
that up Sing Don't Rain on My Parade
do it no I would never do that to you
Turtle no by the way we know you're a
better singer than me take my one song
I've been practicing my whole life I
won't sing it but like genuinely I would
like to hear you sing don't worry about
like you're missing the point I don't
want to
no there's literally like no part of me
that's like drumming up to sing the song
like it's not happening come on give the
people what they want that's not what
they want dirty little they want me
singing The Climb
I don't think so they love when I sing
The Climb yeah okay fine wow Jackie
backing down from a challenge noted yeah
note it note it that's our show that was
a long one we had so much to discuss I
feel better like I took a big dump of
words yummy
reminder that this is our first of Three
episodes this week I'm not here Thursday
Friday I'm heading out of the country
just like Global Cosmopolitan jet
setting girl so Monday Tuesday Wednesday
this week is a short week so we got we
gave you a long episode maybe split this
one in two no well our plan is assuming
that like oh yeah we're able to be uh
you know nothing arises that Thursday
and Friday we will drop patreon episodes
so that you have content if you're a
patreon member and you can always become
a patreon hammer if you're not one yet
so if you are a fully immersed toaster
you actually will have episodes all days
this week yeah true okay thanks for
reminding me for the fvts thank you guys
so much for listening to the toast I
really mean that the millennial Morning
Show where we deliver the past five
stories that you need to know every
Monday through Friday on YouTube so if
you're watching this on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast pretty much anywhere
podcast can be found so Spotify iTunes
Stitch or public radio I already castbox
all the places maybe listen to podcast
my message
we are hope you guys have like literally
the best day the best day for real and
we'll see you tomorrow
I'm a sweet girl it's so sweet turdy Lou
I hope you have a really great day too
we'll see you tomorrow bye we will see
you tomorrow love you bye